brown's coach steven kevin stefanski
will
not be in the building this was news
that came out of the blue and this is
part of the reality of
pro football and a pandemic you never
know when that
tweet when that email when that press
release when that
video conference is going to pop up
saying a key player or a key coach
is unavailable due to testing positive
for covet 19 that's what happened
with the browns coach kevin stefanski
and two assistants
are positive and will not be available
on sunday night
also two players guard joel betonio and
receiver
darrell hodge tested positive for covet
19.
and look they continue to take the
position there's no outbreak in
cleveland that this is all the result of
community spread
that's a hell of a lot of community
spread shireen if it's not an outbreak
absolutely mike it almost seems to me
like the ravens situation and no they
contact tracy's thing so they know where
the virus came from and they know
it's out of the community and not within
player to player i get all that
but it they have had such a high number
now of players who have tested positive
and coaches who have tested positive
within the browns organization
it feels so much like what the ravens
went through
a few weeks ago and and here's the thing
to keep in mind
on sunday when the tweets started to
come out i think shefty had a tweet
that all games were good to go i
checked with the league on brown
steelers and i was told
no brown steelers were still doing
cleveland testing and so far it looks
good but that one hasn't gotten the full
green light yet
and it shows that there was a reason for
the heightened concern
because if and this
this is the combination of doughnut
holes we've talked about all year long
one that relates to the incubation
period and the other that relates to the
delay between
sample collection and the obtaining of
the result when you do the off-site pcr
test
you combine those two things you have
occasions where guys are in the facility
shedding virus and you don't find out
for three to five to seven days
sometimes ten days that someone has
caught it so that's always going to be
there that chain reaction is always
going to be potentially present
and that feels like it's what's
happening with the browns
that kevin stefanski most likely didn't
get it
going home or going to mcdonald's or
going to get gasoline or going to the
grocery store
he got it at work from somebody who was
there
who found out early the next morning
that they had tested positive
from the sample the prior day and they
were in the building all day shedding
virus
it feels like that's the case now
they've yet to say
that's what's happening they're doing
contact tracing and genomic testing and
all of this stuff
but there's just a point where common
sense suggests
that this isn't a simple case of
guys leaving the building and somehow
catching
covet 19 and bringing it back and being
intercepted before they could give it to
someone else
yeah no question about it mike and the
league said all along even in the
postseason they weren't going to
change schedules for competitive reasons
medical reasons only
and i don't know what point this gets to
be a medical reason but the browns
certainly have a more difficult task now
than they did before this game it was
going to be
a big task anyway but now it's going to
be an even bigger task with the players
and the coaches that they're going to be
without including
their play caller kevin stefanski and
now that's going to fall to alex van
pelt so
a lot of things have changed in the last
few days for the browns and this
continues to be ongoing and i'm sure the
nfl and
it almost seems like this is almost to a
crisis point where
at what point do you start thinking
about we're not going to have enough
players we're not going to have enough
coaches but we saw with the lions
almost their entire coaching staff was
out for the one game they played anyway
the broncos didn't have a quarterback
they played anyway
they're going to continue to play
they're going to do everything they
possibly can to get this game in mike no
matter who
the browns have available they're going
to say go out there and play
as long as the league believes there
isn't an ongoing uncontained
outbreak among the browns the game will
proceed
i don't know what the minimum number of
players
available is but i believe the number
is far closer to all but 11 than
69 the full complement is 69 53 on the
roster and 16 practice squad players
that breaking point because they're
going to say next man up
next man up next man up next man up and
i don't know how few they would have to
have before the league says we just
can't do this
same thing with coaches i don't know how
few they'd have to have i think at some
point
jimmy haslam gets to realize the jury
jones dream and coach's own team if it
comes to it
i don't think it comes to that but
they're going to want this game to go
for they're not going to want to delay
it you can't delay it
you can delay it to monday at the latest
if you guarantee the winner plays the
following sunday in the divisional round
you can't delay it to tuesday you can't
put the postseason on hold i guess you
can
you can that's your only alternative is
put all the other games on hold while
you get
cleveland pittsburgh in and then that
next weekend after
cleveland and pittsburgh finally play
assuming they at least get five or six
days in between
that's when you play the next round of
games that's what they would have to do
i mean another thing you could do
frankly you could and i don't want to
get too far into the weeds here
but let's say that you play pittsburgh
on
tuesday pittsburgh cleveland on tuesday
let's say they move the division game
involving the winner of that game to
monday
and then let's say that the following
weekend instead of back-to-back
conference championship games on sunday
you do one sunday night and one monday
night this may be another situation
where they kind of discover plutonium by
accident
as it relates to better broadcasting
windows because that
that would have to at least be a
possibility if i'm the nfl i'm saying
hmm okay
game tuesday night play the division
round game the following monday night
hey monday night prime time hell of a
rating
and then the following monday night
would be the conference championship
game involving the winner
of that game on the monday night that
would be played with the winner of the
pittsburgh cleveland game i
i'm just spitting that out there but i
wouldn't have a problem with that
i wouldn't have a problem with sunday
night monday night conference
championship i wouldn't have a problem
with
three weekend division round games and a
monday night division round game i'm
surprised you haven't done something
like that already
yeah oh i am too mike and i'm surprised
on championship weekend is it it isn't
saturday and sunday nights
i just think there's so many
opportunities there to get these games
in prime time and the more you spread
them out sunday monday
to monday night no yeah they're talk
absolutely
that's where the money is but if you
move everything sunday
sunday monday you're exactly right and
if you do that going forward you're
right you figure out plutonium the
ratings go through the roof and
you know can you imagine though mike if
this game gets changed pittsburgh
now on the on the other end of it yet
again we saw that with the
the ravens and they lost their bye week
and they lost their mini by
and everything got backed up and and can
you imagine pittsburgh's reaction to
this if something like that happens
it would be unbelievable i'd like to
think that this time around the reaction
will be far
different because i would like to think
they'll take a step back and say
we're not as good as we were back when
we complained about
having the ball moved around on us as to
when we're going to play
we should welcome the fact that the
browns are
short-staffed and that the browns are
distracted and that the browns won't
have their head coach because look
they're not going to have kevin
stefanski even if they move the game to
tuesday it's a 10-day mandatory waiting
period this is just a question of a
short delay
if guys end up on the covet 19 reserve
list as being close contacts with some
of these individuals
and guys just aren't available and they
want to give it a little more time but i
i don't
i don't think it comes to that i think
they're going to say this game gets
played sunday night because one of the
concerns about delaying games is
there's no guarantee the game is
ultimately going to get played on the
later date that's another
concern that has permeated the season so
that's where we are and as you mentioned
alex van pelt who once played
quarterback at pitt
will be the browns play caller he did
that some in training camp so it's not
brand new for him and mike prefer
the former vikings special teams
coordinator now the court
coordinator in cleveland will be the the
head coach
for the game hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports